hit by a tractor-trailer killing 13  people  you know some of the most serious  accidents on our roads do involve  tractor trailers and now a group of  lawmakers are trying to pass a lot to  help prevent those collisions  it requires big rigs to have those side  guards you just saw there it would stop  a car  from going under just like that it also  calls for upgraded front and rear guards  on those trucks  critics say these new features would add  weight to a trailer and that could drive  up costs  but advocates think it's a vital change  what do you say the critics that say  it's too expensive and it hurts the  business  how much is a life worth life is worth  more  than any of that the european union has  required those  side guards since 2003.